Daniel is with us in Austin Texas
hi Daniel how are you good sir thank you
for taking my call my walk and I we are
in a heap of trouble
Mac we're maxed out on all of our bills
and you know we're and I'm already
working about 60 70 hours a week at my
job so I'm trying to find out how do we
get this ball rolling in a boss mom
being a mom she's gonna get her business
that okay you're fine your phone's great
your phone's breaking up you're going to
speak directly into it and hold still
okay you know I mean we're just trying
to see you know bills are getting paid
but we're just trying to see you know
how can we get this ball rolling
what is your household income but not
seventy I do about 70,000 a year
good and how much debt do you have I
think I told Kelly about 80 but I think
it's more bar around 90,000 not counting
the house yeah how much do you owe on
your cars that's reading about seven oh
I'm sorry say again about 70,000 I have
two cars and a motorcycle I made a
really bad mistake so what do you owe on
the motorcycle about ten thousand and
what is it worth
I probably right at that I think what
about it what about your car what do you
drive i donít Honda said I think it's
worth about it doesn't and I still owe
49er I'm sorry it's worth about what a
about ten I just flicked it up at Kelly
Blue Book and a tourist about ten
thousand is that private sale yes sir
okay and and in you owe 14 and Mama's
car what do you owe on it I hope I just
got it 45,000 but that was my biggest
mistake is young be turned in her last
one and they rolled about fourteen
thousand mobile okay and so you owe what
on this forty five thousand dollar car
on forty five thousand we just
I just made last week I just made the
first time so the car is worth what I
just looked it up last night right now
it dropped the point out 20,000 yeah I
figured that 30 but I just put it in the
Kelly Blue Book last night okay there's
no way there's no way it drop ten
thousand dollars when you drove it off
the lot
I mean so you had 15 negative equity you
rolled into it yes sir
and how bad is your credit it's um it's
bought mid-range when did you buy this
last car like a month minal probably two
months ago okay
I didn't in the first payment what other
debt have you got between that some like
you know the water filter at the house
you know I mean you know the sales guy
comes eggs how much were you how much
other debt do you have and what's it on
how much you owe on the loan like five
thousand and furniture about six
thousand just paid little 3300 in credit
cards yeah what other toys have you guys
sitting around I have some hard that I
do some wood work some tools and what
are they worth I really can say not a
whole lot I mean maybe a thousand
dollars okay maybe you got an a damper
in the backyard a boat in the backyard
no no no actually we got rid of the
camper okay to get house yeah and how
much do you hole in your home we owe
about 140,000 I can look a year ago it's
legal area who is the loan with on the
forty five thousand dollar car it's
through Chrysler Rogers
yeah it's right at the it was a bit I'm
gonna trust me every bit nine I'm just
sitting here banging my head against the
wall on your stupid
okay there's a couple things we can do
immediately and there's three or four
variables I see in this that you can
start to work on and then the rest of it
you're gonna have to grind through okay
and variable number one is anything you
can do to get your income up or her
income up you said she's starting a
business on the side I'll send her a
copy of Christie Wright's business
boutique book and let's get that going
you see she just got it she was at her
signing a Tuesday night no good okay
okay so you're already on the way with
that good okay and anything you can do
you said you're working like a crazy man
already and I'm not doubting that but
yeah anything you can do to create
income is not a bad thing I would sell
the motorcycle today okay get rid of
that $10,000 were the dad in that
payment that doesn't fix much but it
gets things started in the right
direction your car is not the problem as
you said Mama's car is insanity on
steroids and so what we've got to do
there is start to try to figure out if
there's any way out of this thing I
don't think that car dropped from thirty
thousand to twenty overnight in two
months
I think it either wasn't worth 30 when
you bought it or you got some bad info
won't Kelly Blue Book okay yeah and so
I'm gonna do if I'm you I'm gonna
scratch around and try to figure out I
want to get as much for this car as I
can get and then you've got to figure
out some place to borrow the 15,000 okay
if you can get 30 out of it and have a
fifteen thousand dollar loan down at the
credit union we got rid of thirty
thousand dollars worth of debt we got
rid of ten thousand dollars worth of
debt on the motorcycle now we're
starting to get where we can breathe and
now mama gets a beater car or she gets
your car and you get a thousand dollar
car I don't care which while we get out
of this mess that's not forever but
that's till we get out of this mess yeah
we we thought kind of thought about like
trying to get rid of the van and her
drive my car yeah and then I just cuz
that my car just used for work so I
could drive the motorcycle because it's
on a really cheap payment you know I'm
gonna you don't need a ten thousand
dollar motorcycle not that situation you
need to get a thousand dollar car with
no payments okay you need to get rid of
debt we're trying to you want you've got
is a mathematical log jam there's this
you know too many things trying to get
through to
to narrow a hallway yes follow me and I
ain't dynamite and you need dynamite to
blow it up and that's that's what we're
doing here okay yeah so it's gonna and I
don't know how quickly you're gonna be
able to move out of this car how much
car it may take a few months of screwing
around with us to find the loan and to
find a buyer and everything else it's
not gonna be an easy process the third
thing is the money stretcher is the
budget and that's jump on every dollar
have you done that yet yes sir we
actually after six years we need high
BAM I did a budget how to fight I'll get
it okay all right that's a good that's a
good place to start and if you've got
the every dollar app on your iPhone and
Android or whatever on your desktop and
you and mom are walking through that you
and your wife are working through that
together then you can start to say how
are we gonna get control how are we
gonna get where we can breathe and as
you start beating on this and twisting
all these different knobs you're gonna
start to have some flow again right now
it's all stopped up but it'll start to
flow again gradually and you'll be able
to pull this off I know you're scared
Daniel I've been right where you are
it's hard I will tell you though that if
you will lean into this and keep pushing
all the different buttons the income
getting rid of debt and the budget and
working tightly with your wife on this
you'll push through this you can do it
and I'll be here to help hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]